jeans can be copied they can be
replicated they can be passed around so
can means when I tell you something
which you remember I have taken a mean
and if fifteen of you remember it
I have propagated the meme to 15 new
individuals each one of them is capable
of now passing this meme along provided
they replicated with sufficient fidelity
and this is a problem of information
degradation but if the mean is not
reinforced it Peters out someone says
well what did so-and-so say and then you
get a version that you know is
unrecognizable I have this experience
all the time because people come up to
me and say you know I thought it was
wonderful where you said that and then
they break out with something not only
that I've never said but that I never
could have conceived of and probably
don't agree with so the keeping the
memes straight is very important and the
psychedelic meme is competitive with you
know the just say no need for example
and I believe that on a level playing
field the most open-ended means will
prevail that what is a good mean a good
meme is a meme that doesn't foreclose
its options because as soon as you have
a closed cycle of explanation whether
it's Egyptian theology or Marxist
Leninist there's there's no way out you
know it's like girdles
incommensurability
theorem no formal system can generate
all possible formal statements within
the system in order to keep that auction
open you have to preserve a lack of
closure
and this is one of the things about the
dominator eco that makes it a little
like being stupid to be under the
influence of the Dominator ego it always
searches for closure it always wants to
bring things around and close off the
explanatory cycle because it interprets
open-endedness as a kind of threat a
feminine upwelling or a boundary
dissolving influence